this next story would be sort of dumb
sidebar were it not for the fact that it
goes to the total debasement of American
politics and basic honesty in our
country and it's the story of
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
who's been attacked for a long time for
claiming Native American heritage in her
family she's been ridiculed for this
Donald Trump has made it a habit of
making fun of her by calling her
Pocahontas many times I could play 15
minutes of examples for you here's just
one right just to give you a sense of
how he does it you'll have plenty of
those Democrats coming over and you're
gonna say no sir no thank you no ma'am
perhaps ma'am it may be Pocahontas
remember that
Donald Trump also previously said that
if Elizabeth Warren took a DNA test and
released it and it showed that she had
Native American ancestry or as Trump
likes to call it that she was an Indian
that he would donate a million dollars
to the charity of her choice and
Elizabeth Warren has done that she's
published her DNA results it seems to be
more about 2022 try to be able to say
listen I've dealt with that issue if she
does indeed want to run for president in
2020 then her about then about her
campaign right now here in Massachusetts
which she's going to handily win and a
Stanford professor Carlos Bustamante
who's an expert in data science and
genomics said that as in genomics our
genomics
I guess genomics is genomics I say
genomics said that the vast majority of
Elizabeth Warren's ancestry is European
but that quote the results strongly
support the existence of an unexpected
six and ten generations ago which
critics will point out ten generations
would mean that she is 1/1000 24th
Native American so the immediate
questions were number one why's Warren
doing this now answer again I think it's
about getting it out of the way if she
wants to advance a presidential run in
2020 interestingly Donald Trump is not
ready to donate the million Trump was
asked about this yesterday morning and
he straight-up denied ever having made
the promise to donate a million dollars
check this out
[Music]
okay
now here's Donald Trump himself making
the promise and tell me Pat if my ears
are deceiving me this is from July 5th
where Donald Trump said exactly what he
denied saying there and we will say I
will give you a million dollars to your
favorite charity paid for by Trump if
you take the test and it shows you're an
idiot yeah shows you're an Indian I like
how the crowd cheers that like what are
you what are you cheering there right
well maybe that's providing him covered
right because turns out she's Native
American partially yes not Indian she's
Gia's no she's not claiming any Indian
ancestry dating back to the Indian
subcontinent he can argue he was kidding
he can argue it doesn't really show that
she is Native American if she's only one
1,024 Native American but how can they
argue that he never said it and while
we're at it didn't Sean Hannity say he'd
get waterboarded if something or other
happened and he didn't do it I think
that that's also a promise that I ever
just remembered I would like to see that
maybe he could make it longer than
Mancow Muller did what was that like
four seconds or seconds waterboarding
torture so the latest is Trump says he
will only donate the million if he can
test Elizabeth Warren himself I don't
even know what that means like he's not
he's not a DNA you don't want to know
what that I don't I don't want to know
what Trump imagines it would mean for
him to personally test Elizabeth
Warren's DNA in any case does anybody
find it odd that if you have a drop of
African blood according to some of these
rightists you're black but if you have a
Native American
great-great-great-grandmother you're not
Native American and it's okay to mock
you as Pocahontas and I want to be like
crystal clear here okay if you are
arguing that Elizabeth Warren has not
experienced setbacks in her life on the
basis of being Native American I'm with
you okay I have seen no evidence
whatsoever that whether or not Elizabeth
Warren is 1024 through one five hundred
and twelfth or whatever it is Native
American I have seen no evidence
whatsoever that she has suffered
setbacks in her experience in life as a
wealthy sixty something year
woman if I'm wrong show me the evidence
there is no question whatsoever here
that her Native American heritage is
minor it's more than mine I mean I have
none like I have no Native American
Heritage period in my background so she
is more than me but does it relate to
her experience as a person in the United
States of America no I don't think so
but if I had an Italian great-great
great-grandmother would it be okay to
start calling me
Guido sarcastically or whatever right
like if I had an Irish ancestor is it
acceptable for the president to jokingly
mock me as Mick or something that's the
point here which is again the debasement
of the politics and if you want to come
to me and say no David the real problem
here is that Elizabeth Warren actually
received an advantage on the basis of
claiming this Native American heritage
come to me and prove that because I've
not seen that people who say well she
was classified at Harvard as Native
American that's different than being an
affirmative action admission on that
basis and I've not seen evidence of that
to the contrary there was a
comprehensive Boston Globe study that
looked into this yeah and it proves just
that that she wasn't admitted on the
basis of her being Native American and
that wasn't even considered it was more
just about how she was listed in the
faculty directory yes she wasn't doing
this to get ahead or anything like that
and again I don't believe that there
would be any reason to afford her that
getting ahead because I don't believe
that she was hindered in any way by this
supposed Native American heritage which
we now were told by a genomics that
award that that it is a likely part of
her of her ancestry send me your
thoughts about where you are on this